SEEING EVEN MORE EVIDENCE THAT
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
ENTERTAINERS AT FOX KNEW EXACTLY
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
WANTS TO CHAT WITH SEAN HANNITY.
WHY?
BECAUSE AS PART OF ITS
INVESTIGATION EVEN MORE TEXT
MESSAGES THERE ARE SURFACING
THAT THE FOX HOST WAS IN THE
VERY MIDDLE OF STRATEGY SESSIONS
WITH THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE WHITE HOUSE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT HANNITY
WAS SAYING PRIVATELY WAS FAR
FROM THE MESSAGE THAT HE AND HIS
NETWORK PUSHED PUBLICLY TO ITS
VIEWERS.
MANY OF WHOM WOULD MARCH ON THE
CAPITOL.
>> ON LEFT SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN,
YOU WILL HEAR HANNITY'S WORDS TO
VIEWERS.
ON THE RIGHT, YOU WILL SEE HIS
PRIVATE TEXT TO TRUMP ALLIES,
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, WE REPORT,
YOU DECIDE.
>> WE HAVE TED CRUZ COMING ON
LATER ON IN THE PROGRAM.
HE WANTS THE COMMISSION TO LOOK
INTO THIS FOR TEN DAYS.
WE'LL HAVE 150 HOUSE MEMBERS
SUPPORTING THIS AS WELL.
BIG RALLY.
I BELIEVE YOUR DAD WILL BE
ADDRESSING THAT RALLY TOMORROW.
BIG CROWDS SHOWED UP TO THE
POINT WHERE THE WEST WING COULD
HEAR THE MUSIC AND THE CHANTING
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE
ALREADY.
AND THIS ALL KICKS OFF IN THE
MORNING TOMORROW.
>> WELL, SEAN, THAT'S RIGHT.
AND TOMORROW IS AN IMPORTANT
DAY.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION, I
BELIEVE, TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION.
AND TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM.
>> SENATOR, I'M LOOKING AT THE
SUPPORT YOU'RE GETTING IN THE
SENATE, I'M LOOKING AT THE
SUPPORT IN THE HOUSE, MAYBE 150
MEMBERS IN THE END.
IT IS LOOKING LIKE REALISTALLY,
CAN THIS REALLY HAPPEN?
I DON'T LIKE TO GIVE THIS
AUDIENCE FALSE HOPE.
WOULD WE HAVE AN AUDIT?
IS THAT REAL?
IS THAT A POSSIBILITY?
DO YOU SEE, FOR EXAMPLE -- DO
YOU SEE ANY AFTER TOMORROW IS
THERE A PATH FOR THE PRESIDENT
CONSTITUTIONALLY?
>> AS YOU SAW FROM THE TEXT
THERE, WE'LL GET INTO MUCH MORE
ABOUT WHAT THEY ACTUALLY SAY,
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE VERY
IMPORTANT THERE FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION.
HANNITY KNEW THERE WAS NO PATH,
KNEW THERE WAS NO CONSTITUTIONAL
PATH, BUT HE BUILT UP THE RALLY,
HE GAVE VOICE TO PEOPLE LIKE TED
CRUZ PUSHING THE BIG LIE.
YOU SHOULD REMEMBER, FOX IS
BEING SUED FOR BILLIONS FOR ITS
LIES ABOUT THE ELECTION.
AND THEN AFTER THE INSURRECTION,
HANNITY, DESPITE ACCURATELY
PREDICTING THAT CHAOS WOULD
HAPPEN, FLOATED CONSPIRACIES AND
LIES ABOUT LEFT WING ACTORS
BEING THE CULPRITS.
>> WE ALSO KNEW THAT THERE IS
ALWAYS BAD ACTORS THAT WILL
INFILTRATE LARGE CROWDS.
THOSE WHO TRULY SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THOSE THAT
BELIEVE THEY'RE PART OF THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY, YOU DO NOT -- WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THOSE THAT COMMIT ACTS
OF VIOLENCE.
>> PEACEFULLY PROTEST.
WE HEARD GROUPS LIKE ANTIFA,
OTHER RADICAL GROUPS, THEY WERE
THERE TO CAUSE TROUBLE.
>> HANNITY AND FOX, THEY SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TELLING VIEWERS WHAT
THEY THINK IS PATRIOTISM.
BUT JUST TO RECAP HERE,
HANNITY'S NETWORK PUBLICLY SOLD
THE BIG LIE, THEY BUILT IT UP,
SO THAT A PRESIDENT COULD CARRY
OUT A COUP, A BLATANT ATTACK ON
DEMOCRACY.
THEIR VIEWERS ARE BEING LIED TO.
BRAINWASHED, MANIPULATED, AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR, FOX IS NOT A
NEWS NETWORK, WHICH IS NOT
BREAKING NEWS, I WILL SAY.
>> JOINING US NOW, DAVID GREGORY
AND FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR ALISA
FARRAH GRIFFIN.
I WANT TO READ ONE OF THE
HANNITY TEXTS FIRST AGAIN.
I DO THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THE INVESTIGATION HERE.
AND IT IS VERY SHORT.
HE WRITES ON JANUARY 5th, I'M
VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE NEXT 48
HOURS.
SO THE SELECT COMMITTEE POINTS
OUT CORRECTLY, WHY?
WHY WAS THIS PERSON WHO WAS IN
CONSTANT CONTACT WITH PEOPLE
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT WAS ABOUT TO HAPPEN?
WHAT DID HE KNOW ABOUT THE PLANS
THAT WERE IN PLACE THAT WERE
ABOUT TO HAPPEN?
IT REALLY IS A WORTHY QUESTION.
>> IT IS A VERY WORTHY QUESTION
AND I CAN'T FORESEE ANY SCENARIO
WHERE SEAN HANNITY ISN'T
COMPELLED TO TESTIFY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
HE'S WORRIED IN EITHER ONE
DIRECTION OR THE OTHER THAT HE
KNEW THAT THIS DAY WAS GOING TO
GET VIOLENT AND GOING TO BE A
MAR ON OUR AMERICAN DEMOCRACY OR
HE WAS WORRIED AS HIS TEXTS SEEM
TO REVEAL KNOWING PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAD LOST THE ELECTION.
HE WAS NOT GOING TO WIN, THERE
WAS NO PATH FOR RECOURSE, THE
RESULTS WERE NOT GOING TO BE
OVERTURNED AND WHAT THAT WOULD
MEAN FOR TRUMP, HOW HE WOULD
HANDLE IT.
AND I THINK -- LISTEN, THIS KIND
OF TENUOUS EFFORT TO SAY THAT
SEAN HANNITY IS A JOURNALIST AND
THAT MIGHT GIVE HIM SOME KIND OF
COVERAGE TO NOT HAVE TO COMPLY,
JUST DOESN'T PASS THE SMELL
TEST.
HE'S VERY MUCH AN OPINION
COMMENTATOR.
AND HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO SPEAK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
>> WHAT HE SAYS HIMSELF, HE SAYS
HE'S NOT A JOURNALIST TO BE
CLEAR.
HE SAYS HE'S A HOST.
BUT I WONDER, DAVID, THESE
TEXTS, WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST
ISSUES THAT THEY BRING UP FOR
YOU.
>> WELL, I THINK AS ALISA SAYS,
IT IS BEING IN DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE I
THINK THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF HOW MUCH THE
PRESIDENT UNDERSTOOD ABOUT WHAT
HE WAS UNLEASHING AND WHAT THE
INTENDED AFFECT OF IT WAS.
AND IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT HE
AND HIS CHIEF OF STAFF ARE
GETTING -- GETTING THESE KINDS
OF WARNINGS FROM STRAIGHT UP
ALLIES, FOR, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PROPAGANDISTS ON FOX NEWS WHO
ARE CERTAINLY TOEING HIS LINE
AND THEY'RE THE ONES SAYING THIS
HAS GOT TO STOP OR IN THIS CASE,
HANNITY PREEMPTIVELY SAYING THIS
IS GOING TO BE A HORRIBLE
OUTCOME.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
WHETHER IT IS TO THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF OR TO MARK MEADOWS, HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF, AT THE TIME.
AND I THINK, LOOK, THE TEXTS ARE
ALREADY VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE HAD ACCESS
TO, THAT THE COMMITTEE HAD
ACCESS TO BECAUSE IT SHOWS YOU
WHAT PEOPLE WERE SAYING WHEN
THEY DIDN'T THINK THE WHOLE
WORLD WAS WATCHING.
SO IT IS REALLY QUITE REVEALING.
NOW, IF THERE IS ALL THIS
JOCKEYING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
HE ACTUALLY COOPERATES OR
TESTIFIES, THAT MAY BE A LITTLE
BIT BESIDE THE POINT.
>> I'M WITH YOU, IT IS ALREADY
REVEALING THAT HE HAD
FOREKNOWLEDGE THAT SOMETHING WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHY?
WHAT WAS BEING DISCUSSED?
WHAT DID HE KNOW ABOUT WHAT WAS
BEING DISCUSSED?
THE FACT THAT HE HAD
FOREKNOWLEDGE TELLS YOU JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
SCHEDULED TO HOLD A NEWS
CONFERENCE AT MAR-A-LAGO
TOMORROW, THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY.
BUT HE CANCELED.
HE CANCELED.
AND OUR REPORTING IS BECAUSE HE
WAS PISSED OFF THAT PEOPLE
WEREN'T GOING TO COVER IT, THERE
WAS A LACK OF INTEREST AROUND
HIS NEWS CONFERENCE TOMORROW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENED HERE?
>> I THINK THAT'S VERY LIKELY.
THAT REPORTING IS TRUE.
I HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT GREW A
CONSCIENCE AND REALIZED THAT
THIS WAS -- THIS IS A SOLEMN DAY
AND IT WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE TO
SPOUT HIS ELECTION LIES WHILE
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY GRIEVES
THAT HORRIBLE DAY.
IT IS CERTAINLY THAT IT WASN'T
GOING TO BREAKTHROUGH AND I
WOULD NOTE IN THE STATEMENT THAT
HE CAN'T -- HE ANNOUNCES HE'S
CANCELING IT, HE CONTINUES TO
CARRY ON THE BIG LIE.
AND THEN HE MAKES THIS VERY
ABSURD CLAIM THAT I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE, SAYING
PELOSI DIDN'T DEPLOY THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
SHE COULD HAVE DONE IT IN
ADVANCE.
SO HE INCITED A RIOT, THEN THE
RIOT GOES TO THE CAPITOL,
ATTACKS IT, AND THEN HE'S
BLAMING NANCY PELOSI THAT SHE
WASN'T PREPARED TO, YOU KNOW,
TAKE ON THIS RIOT THAT HE
INCITED.
SO HE'S -- THERE -- IT TAKE A
LOT OF MENTAL GYMNASTICS FOR HIM
TO DEFEND HIMSELF ON THIS DAY.
AND I THINK IT IS VERY WISE THAT
HE'S CHOOSING TO NOT SPEAK.
>> IT IS PROBABLY -- IT IS FOR
THE BEST, DAVID, FOR EVERYONE.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF HIM HAVING THIS
PRESSER AND HE'S JUST GOING TO
BE PROPAGATING THE BIG LIE, HE'S
DOING IT, IT IS ALMOST LIKE A
BATTLE CRY, A YEAR LATER.
>> YEAH, AND THE VALVE OF HIS
SPEAKING AND HIS VIEWS HAS BEEN
DIMINISHED.
I ALSO THINK HE'S -- NOSETHOSE E
TO HIM HAVE TO MAKE A
CALCULATION ABOUT HOW TO TREAT
JANUARY 6th.
IF THERE IS A POLITICAL FUTURE
HERE FOR DONALD TRUMP, HE WANTS
TO TRY TO RECAST WHAT IT WAS,
WHAT IT MEANT, HOW IT HAPPENED
BECAUSE HE HAS TURNED OFF SO
MANY PEOPLE ALREADY WITH HIS
ROLE.
WHETHER THAT'S DETERMINATIVE OF
WHETHER THE FOLKS WHO SUPPORTED
HIM WOULD STILL VOTE FOR HIM OR
NOT, WE DON'T REALLY KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT.
BUT I THINK AT ANY POLITICAL
LEVEL HE WOULD BE SMART TO TRY
TO STEP ASIDE AND LET OTHER
PEOPLE TRY TO CAST IT AS
SOMETHING OTHER THAN WE ALL KNOW
THAT IT WAS.
WHICH IS WHAT TAKES ME BACK TO
WHAT WE ARE LEARNING FROM THESE
FOX PERSONALITIES WHO WERE
IMPLORING THE WHITE HOUSE TO
TAKE A DIFFERENT TURN.
THESE ARE FOLKS DRIVING A FALSE
NARRATIVE AROUND ALL OF THIS.
IN THE CRITICAL MOMENTS, WHEN
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD THE
PRESIDENCY OR THE CHIEF OF
STAFF'S EAR, THEY WERE WAVING A
RED FLAG SAYING THIS IS
HORRIBLE, THIS IS WRONG, YOU'RE
GOING TO RUIN EVERYTHING WITH
THIS.
THAT WAS THE MOST HONEST
APPRAISAL THAT WE HAVE SEEN.
>> STILL, LET ME BOOK TED CRUZ,
SO HE CAN SPOUT THE VERY LIES
THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SPOUTING THERE.
>> BUT I WILL SAY, EVEN IN THAT
CLIP, JOHN, EVEN IN THAT CLIP,
IF YOU WATCH IT CLOSELY, THE WAY
I SEE IT IS, YOU KNOW, HANNITY
AT THE END THERE IS SAYING,
THERE IS NOT REALLY ANY CHANCE
THIS IS GOING TO WORK.
I DON'T WANT TO SELL ANY FALSE
HOPE TO PEOPLE, BUT HE'S
STILL -- HE'S STILL ADVANCING
IT.
I'M NOT DENYING THAT.
>> I SAW THE EXACT -- I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I SAW THE EXACT SAME THING
THERE, DAVID.
CLEARLY HE DIDN'T BELIEVE IT AND
WAS SORT OF HALF SAYING IT, YET
HE STILL PUT THE GUY ON